Eddie is with us in Fairfax Virginia
hi Eddie how are you hey David how are
you doing today better than I deserve
what's up in your world sir I have a
question for you so I have a car payment
which is actually my only debt right now
however the interest rate on it is
pretty pretty bad it's at 22% yeah and
and today I went online and got the
payoff quote that's at about fifteen
thousand one hundred and fifty so I've
kind of been seeing some of your videos
where you talk about you know sell the
car which I'm totally fine with I have a
backup I guess my main question is
what's the lowest I should take on the
on the car if I'm taking it to a
dealership now I do have money in my
savings that I can put towards I guess
the balance of to try to get out of this
loan as quick as possible okay so how
much do you have in savings not counting
a retirement five thousand five thousand
five hundred fifty five hundred okay and
what is your household income about
seventy-two thousand a year okay and are
you single no I'm married but my wife
stays home with the kids okay all right
because okay and the other car what is
it worth the one that's paid problem I
don't know but I can't say that's
probably not much because I only bought
it for about three grand
okay so you got a $3,000 car do you have
a third car then - no no just two cars
okay you have the $3,000 car and a
$15,000 car give or take right okay so
my rule of thumb on cars is this if you
can become debt-free inside of two years
and if your vehicle totals all together
are less than half your annual income
and you want to keep the car then keep
it so I don't have a problem with you
keeping this car because you easily
could pay it off inside of two years
making seventy two thousand especially
if you throw you know if you do our baby
steps baby step 1 is $1,000 you keep
that much in the account you throw the
other four
at the car that gets you down to 11 how
fast can you pay off 11 making 72 4
months
yeah probably pretty quick yeah four or
five months I mean if it was your main
thing right and that gets rid of this
ridiculous interest rate which your
income doesn't tell me why your interest
rate is high it must be you have bad
credit
I did have horrible credit when I got
the car my credit was really bad cuz
they took you to the cleaners oh yeah
they saw you coming hey there comes
Eddie let's get Eddie right look at that
there's Eddie right walking up the lot
and boom yeah Wow
so pay the thing off or I'm gonna sell
it but I don't I don't see a financial
reason to sell it unless you just don't
like it anyway you want to know I
wouldn't sell it back to a dealer I
would sell it for a private sale there's
no panic here you said this is your only
debt to accept your home correct well
I'm actually um so I want to sell the
car because I want to eventually start
saving for a down payment on a home okay
well what's your - - so I mean if you
could do this in really really fast
I mean you throw for at it now we got 11
150 and then I take 11,000 bucks and I
divide that into 72 and I'm going I mean
we're gonna get on your budget and beans
and rice rice and beans you guys are
gonna do a written plan on every dollar
and announced to the children we are
staying home but we're keeping the car
so you know and we're getting this thing
paid off and we're gonna get paid off
really fast and once that's done you
move on to baby step three which is with
no payments in the world you build up
your emergency fund you take that
thousand dollars its left build it back
up to three to six months of expenses
grandma's rainy day fund and then you
start saving for your down payment on
your house by this time next year you're
thinking about a house probably
realistically but that's if you guys
sacrifice and quit screwing around with
money y'all been really sloppy yeah I
was - that's how I can see it yeah I can
see it in the math it's not it doesn't
mean you're sloppy I just said you were
sloppy like you said I used to have this
but yeah you change you make a change
so if you want to sell it it'll
accelerate it but it really won't
accelerate you getting a house if you do
what I'm teaching here but about three
months maybe four okay and so I'm just
gonna pound that car in the face and
keep it and then but you know we when
you look at stuff like this you say you
haven't never again moment never again
well I put myself emotionally in a
situation where someone could take me to
the cleaners like this because I mean if
you look in if you look in the mirror
you're gonna see holes in your lip cuz
they hooked you man I mean like a big
bass wing you know I mean it's like the
real ones going right and so you gotta
go never again am i biting on shiny
stuff again cuz I got a hole in my lip
you know never again cuz I've done a lot
of stupid stuff in my life my only goal
is to not is to know I don't have a goal
to be so careful I never make a mistake
my only goal is not make the same one
twice just don't repeat it and so you've
had your stupid moment on the car lot
high interest rate mistake get that
sucker paid off put it in your past
forget it except to the extent you
promise yourself never again never again
will I'll be on the car lot
unless I'm laying Benjamin Franklin's
across the hood fanned out so that they
know we're paying cash I'm not going on
there I don't I'm not even gonna think
about being around something I can't pay
cash for and that's what I would do if I
were in your shoes